[Musique]
thierry renard bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux élections législatives
oui et vous vous présentez sur la
circonscription de fort de france sur la
lys les insoumis de martinique tout à
fait alors pourquoi vous présentez-vous
à ce scrutin ben c'est le troisième tour
des élections présidentielles et ce
scrutin va nous permettre de faire en
sorte que jean luc mélenchon soit le
premier ministre parce que s'il ya
suffisamment de députés un soumis à
l'assemblée nationale mais l'enfant sera
premier ministre quels sont les deux ou
trois projets prioritaires pour la
martinique que vous souhaitez défendre
si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
or vous savez déjà il ya beaucoup d'
urgence ici nous avons déjà l'urgence
sanitaire c'est à dire il ya déjà le
problème de l'eau il ya des problèmes
qui sont liés à la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants qui fait que
les soignants sont suspendus il faudra
régler tous ces problèmes a déjà en
réintégrant tous les soignants
ça c'est la première chose à faire la
deuxième chose c'est une urgence sociale
urgence sociale c'est parce que les prix
sont prohibitifs ici en martinique et il
faudra d'abord baisser les prix puis les
bloquer comme on va baisser par exemple
les prix du carburant et les bloquer à
nouveau 40 ça veut dire que ça ne pourra
pas dépasser en euros 40 et vous avez la
dernière fois le président république à
baisser baisser de 15 centimes mais le
président de la ctm a décidé d'augmenter
de 29 centimes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les martiniquais paye
plus cher avec une baisse quel autre
dossier vous souhaiteriez défendre
justement pour la martinique vous avez
droit à trois priorités trois dossiers
prioritaires alors vous savez tout est
lié dans notre programme vous avez un
dossier environnemental mais vous avez
aussi la violence par exemple nous
ici à la martinique nous avons choisi et
c'est une bonne chose puisque ça a été
intégrée dans le programme l'avenir en
commun de faire en sorte de faire
revenir le sport à l'école le sport à
l'école ça permet comme il y a quelques
années de cela de faire qui est des
tournois sportifs entre les différents
établissements depuis l'école primaire
ce qui empêche aux jeunes de traîner
dans la rue et l'oisiveté est mère de
tous les vices eh ben on se retrouve
avec ce qu'on a aujourd'hui donc il faut
remettre les jeunes à l'école il faut
faire aussi en sorte que ces jeunes
quand ils sont à l'école ils puissent
subvenir à leurs besoins et na li ne pas
aller chercher un petit job à droite et
à gauche et c'est pour ça que nous
allons mettre une
allocation qui va permettre d'avoir une
autonomie pour ces jeunes de
fonctionnement donc mille 63 euros et
ils vont à l'école ils font pas de
petits boulots ils sont la voile à
l'école la troisième priorité je vous
parlais aussi de ski l'environnement
mais il faut manger sainement manger bio
donc il faudra faire en sorte qu'on
produise bio il y a beaucoup de talent
et des gens ne savent peut-être pas mais
dans les hauteurs de balata au niveau de
tivoli il ya beaucoup de terre des
centaines d'hectares qui sont là en
friche et ils se sont pas des terres qui
ont été pollués n'est pas au chlordécone
ou quoi que ce soit donc c'était un
peuvent être mises à disposition des
agriculteurs ben faudra les auditionner
les mettre à disposition de scop de coop
pour faire en sorte que nous puissions
produit au bio et manger bio une de mes
priorités ce sera de pousser un dossier
qui s'appelle les signes de balata qui
est sûr justement le camp de balata et
vous aussi
le camp de balata sion étendant les
auditeurs de balata vous voulez faire là
précisément non c'est pas moi il ya une
association qui va prendre une partie du
camp de balata et absalon et il veut
faire en sorte et ben de faire de
l'agriculture mais aussi
c'est pour permettre pour les maladies
cardiovasculaires donc ce sera comme un
sanatorium et jean proulx vont venir
pouvant se soigner respirer l'air pur de
de balata parce que fort de france mais
aussi de l'hérault il n'y a pas que la
ville basse donc donc c'est un projet ça
s'appelle les signes de balata qui est
là depuis 2018 dans des cartons ça fait
quatre ans il ya l'argent mais il manque
une seule chose la volonté politique
alors nous nous aurons cette volonté
politique de faire avancer ces projets
là alors qu'est ce que vous pourriez
dire est que vous auriez envie de dire
aux électeurs vous pouvez vous adresser
je dirais aux électeurs qu'il faut aller
voter le troisième tour il faut faire
barrage à maquereau ou au tout et à tous
les mac ronis même s'ils se cachent
derrière d'autres sigles il faut savoir
que il y a une équipe qui s'appelle
l'alliance martinique alice martinez qui
a world scènes de danse dance et macau
nice et les mac os 10 restants sommes
donc tous ceux qui sont avec zen comme
johnny georges ce sont des macros nice
donc il ne faut pas voter pour des
mâconnais sinon on va se retaper 50
macron avec bien entendu tout ce que ça
implique c'est-à-dire au couvre-feu
pas sanitaires et ses vaccinations
obligatoires et si vous voulez que le
past three parce qu'alors il faudra
voter pour des insoumis et faire en
sorte que jean luc mélenchon soit le
premier ministre de la france thierry
renard merci c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]